تمثل جهود الاتحاد الاوروبي ومن قبله
مجموعه الدول الصناعيه السبع الكبرى في
وضع سقف سعر اعلى لنفط الروسي محاوله اخرى
للضغط المالي على موسكو التي يمثل لها
تصدير النفط الخام واحدا من اهم مصادر
تمويل خزينه الدوله وبالتالي تمويل الحرب
على اوكرانيا فما الذي تعنيه بالضبط هذه
الخطوه الزام الدول المستهلكه للنفط
الروسي بعدم تجاوز السقف الاعلى لسعر
برميل النفط في عقود الشراء المباراه مع
موسكو دون النظر الى السعر الحالي الذي
يباع فيه النفط في الاسواق العالميه ففي
حال اعتمد السقف عند 60 دولارا ووصل سعر
برميل النفط عالميا الى 120 دولارا فان
عقود الشراء بين موسكو والمستهلكين لنفقها
يجب ان لا تزيد على ذلك السقف وما سيدفع
اكثر منه ولو بسنت واحد فسيجد نفسه في
مرمى العقوبات الغربيه
لكن استمرار الجدل داخل البيت الاوروبي
بشان السقف الذي يجب ان تعتمده لسعر النفط
الروسي لا يزال يعطل حتى الان الوصول الى
اتفاق يرضي كل الاطراف
استدفع دول مثل قبرص واليونان ومالطا
باتجاه رفع السقف لاعلى قدر ممكن لاعتماد
جزء من اقتصادها على الشحن البحري في حين
تضغط دول مثل بولندا و ليتوانيا واسبانيا
لخفض السقف فالحديث عن سعرا يراويح بين 65
دولارا للبرميل كما اقترحت الدول السبع
الكبرى او 62 دولارا كما مقترح داخل
المناقشات الاوروبيه لن يضر موسكو برايها
ولا يمكن ان يشكل اي ضغط عليها لان الخامه
الروسي يتداول حاليا بحدود ثلاثه و60$
[موسيقى]
وبولندا بان يكون السقف الاعلى لبرميل
النفط الروسي نحو ثلاثين دولارا فقط وهي
خطوه تخشى اطراف غربيه ان تدفع روسيا الى
حظر تصدير نفطها الخام ما قد يؤدي الى
ازمه في سوق الطاقه واشتعال اسعار النفط
اضافه الى ان اكبر مستهلكين للنفط الروسي
هما الصين والهند ولا يتوقع ان يتجاوبان
مع اي خطوه غربيه لفرد سقف اعلى سعره لكنه
ورقه الضغط الاهم للدول الغربيه هي في
ملكيتها لقرابه 90% من شركات التامين
الخاصه بالملاحه البحريه في العالم وفي
حال حضره التعامل مع شحنات الخمرسي ما لم
يتم بيعها باقل من السعر الذي حدثت سقفه
فانه سيصعب جدا على موسكو بيعه نفقها بسعر
اعلى من ذلك السقف